they tamed and rode and deployed in war
dragons hey everybody its charlie so you
may have heard this past week they
confirm the release date for George RR
Martin's new book fire and Blood Part 1
is coming November 12th in Germany they
even showed off the cover here is
basically the complete history of the
Targaryen family all the way from
Aegon's conquest right up to the death
of the Mad King so we've gotten little
bits of that and some of the anthologies
that he's published in the last year
like the sons of the Dragon about Aegon
sons and his Targaryen and make or the
cruel the one who created the dragon pit
that we saw during season 7 I spent a
little bit of last year talking about
him during my bonus videos if you are
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Game of Thrones
videos so I'll try to explain what's
going on what else they're going to
include and they confirmed about this
fire and blood book because it's gonna
be like the big thing that happens this
year obviously winds of winter is still
a long ways off I'm not expecting that
till sometime around when the show drops
next year maybe even the end of next
year like he's pulled back and back on
his public appearances so much that I
actually do think there's a good chance
that we get it in the next couple of
years but what happened is is a lot of
this fire and blood material is just
deleted things that got thrown out from
the main series from A Song of Ice and
Fire and then again when he was making
world of Ice and Fire a couple years ago
there was so much stuff in that that he
also sort of started collecting it into
what would become fire and blood and
then even then he decided there was way
too much for just one fire in blood book
so it's gonna be a two-part volume so
this November release date or at least
the German release date I assume the
International release dates will be
relatively close to that so that means
we start with Aegon's conquest we got
like a little preface for that during
the world of Ice and Fire book but then
there's the period they call the piece
of the Dragon which is still during
Aegon's reign before his death the sons
of the Dragon which I just previously
mentioned a second ago which also
includes the reign of Johar's the first
he's known as Joe Harris the wise he's
the one that ascended to the throne
after make earth accrual died under
suspicious circumstances on his throne
the next confirmed period has just
referred to as the heirs of the Dragon
which is Joe Harris the first reign
through his grandson Viserys the first
rain then the dying of the Dragons which
is basically the period that covers the
dance of the dragons the Targaryen Civil
War they call it the dying of the drag
because so many dragons died during that
period pretty self-explanatory that's
probably the most likely candidate for
what they're doing for the game of
thrones prequel series but we haven't
got any confirmation about that but you
can see how they're gonna have a giant
template for that just whoever becomes
the showrunner and produces it and then
the sort of last confirmed period is
called the aftermath the boy king in his
regions which is Aegon the third the
person to ascend the throne directly
after the dance of the Dragons after
that civil war was over he ascended but
he was a boy king so there was a Regency
he died about a hundred and forty years
before the death of the Mad King so
that's basically like half of that book
you have to imagine that maybe there'll
be some more in there that he hasn't
talked about yet but for the most part
the rest of that period of history like
everything after Aegon the third through
the Mad King is gonna be in volume two
but if you haven't read them and you
want to read those short stories about
these periods in history it's the
princess and the Queen rogue Prince
which is actually I think kind of a
prequel to that and then sons of the
Dragon which was published more recently
back in October the funny thing is is
like obviously this is all deleted
material from the main series but you
think of it as just being really quick
excerpts it's actually a pretty sizable
material in the way that it reads is a
little bit different from the main
novels so if you haven't read the books
they're actually told from point-of-view
chapters meaning it's all first-person
so like you get a Tyrion chapter where
you hear him thinking to himself then
you sort of float to third-person as he
has conversations with other people but
for the most part you're hearing him
think about what's going on moment to
moment and it's the same for all the
other characters they get point-of-view
chapters but these other short stories
as well as the material from world of
Ice and Fire is told from the
perspective of a maester so you're like
you're listening to this old librarian
type person read about these events as
if they've already happened like he's
remembering them as he's writing them
down in the book if you don't know about
the dance of the dragons or you don't
know why the war started or who's the
different factions were the reason why
it's such a big deal is it was happening
during a time of relative prosperity in
the history of the Targaryen family in
the Kingdom but it was a war of
succession so as you do there were
people within the Targaryen family that
felt like they had a stronger claim to
the throne so was on but it all
started when King Viserys the first had
three children with his first wife you
can kind of already see with the
direction I'm going with
only one survived to adulthood it was a
female her name was rhaenyra so
eventually he started to groom her to
become his successor to take the throne
so she got the proper education she got
to sit in on affairs of state small
council meetings all the education and
experience that you would give to
someone that was being groomed to become
the future leader of Westeros but the
thing is is that the year after he
formally named her his heir he remarried
to a Hightower and then had children
with her here's a little clip from some
of the histories and lore bonus features
that they released detailing this this
is actually the actress that played
Shireen Baratheon doing the intro then
Viserys Targaryen Harry Lloyd from the
TV show narrating the body of it the
dance of dragons a true telling' by
grand mr. Monken being a history of the
war of Targaryen succession between the
princess rhaenyra and aegon ii of his
name that nearly destroyed the realm the
dance of the dragons a stupid name for a
Targaryen Civil War where my ancestors
danced away my birthright
before the war House Targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few Targaryen 's we would
never be as powerful or as feared again
the dance began as many dancers do with
an old man and a young girl the Queen
had failed to produce a son for her king
so he anointed his daughter the princess
rhaenyra as his heir but years later the
king remarried and his new wife queen
alicent of house Hightower
gave him a son feeble and foolish the
old king refused to change the
succession he didn't even see how is
called had split into two rival camps of
blacks and greens after the dresses of
the princess and the Queen had worn to
some Tony
one night a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep and ran to inform
queen alicent protocol dictated that the
bells would be rung and a raven sent to
Dragonstone to some in the air princess
rhaenyra for her coronation but allison
had other plans once she saw her dead
husband's body she sealed the room and
have a servant thrown into the black
cells to ensure his silence at the hour
of the owl the Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard so Kristen Cole summoned the
small Council to inform them of the
King's death so Otto Hightower the hand
of the king and fathered the queen
alicent demanded that the succession be
settled immediately the decrepit old men
of the small council were confused
the succession was settled in their
minds the old king had forced the lords
of westeros to swear fealty to princess
rhaenyra as his heir it's a Christian
call rightly pointed out that a son
comes before a daughter the council
argued until dawn when the master of
coin finally stood up and declared he
would have no part of treason so Kristen
Cole wisely opened his trunk with a
dagger ending the debate he was crowned
in the dragon pit and his wife and
sister Helena became queen his brother
Amon flew off to win over the few great
lords who support Aegon didn't already
have the banner of the gold dragon flew
over King's Landing in the red key as
Aegon second of his name ascended the
iron throne he would not sit at long
when ravens carried the news of Aegon
it's coronation to Dragonstone princess
rhaenyra summoned her own blanc council
with her was her uncle and husband
daemon targaryen considered by many to
be the most dangerous man in Westeros
few Lords supported her but the greatest
of these was corliss valerian who
controlled the largest fleet in the
realm and his Targaryen wife Rhaenys the
old King's sister then there were her
five sons although none grown to manhood
a pitiful assembly really combined they
couldn't match the power of house
Hightower alone but rhaenyra had dragons
she Damon and Rhaenys rode huge and
formidable beasts and three of her five
sons were riders as well Dragonstone
also held six more dragons without
riders against this king aegon had only
four dragons of his own so that's how
people started to pick sides in the war
as the factions started to grow and
eventually it broke out into all-out war
ultimately what ended up happening is
the princess rhaenyra son aegon the
third became the future king of Westeros
so ultimately you could say that the
blacks won the war but I'm glossing over
a lot of history so if we do find out
that we're actually gonna get that
during the prequel series obviously
we'll spend a lot more time talking
about it and then when the book gets
released later this year - so let me
know in the comments if you want me to
do more bonus videos about that period
in history but obviously I'll do a book
giveaway when they do drop it I'll let
you guys know when they confirm the US
release date but like I said if it's
gonna be November in the UK it's gonna
be pretty close to that everywhere else
around the world so while you wait for
everything you can click here to listen
to George R Martin read a chapter from
winds of winter and you can click here
for brand new Avengers infinity war
footage thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you